of enchanting there's a new immersive
experience that tells a classic story in
a modern way in just 30 minutes and it's
nothing short of a Whimsical winter
Miracle right on the Strip of Rocky
stopped by to give us a preview
now if you've had any trouble getting
into the holiday spirit I think this
will help Amy introduce us to this new
immersive experience thank you this is
the immersive Nutcracker a winter
miracle and we're so thrilled to be
starting off the holiday season here at
the shops at Crystals oh my God you said
miracle and it really is I see families
and kids frolicking through here sitting
down enjoying the experience now what
are we watching tell us about the story
that we're going to learn from today it
is The Nutcracker and we've brought it
back to life in an immersive experience
from video to cartoon taking you on the
Journey of Marie and the Nutcracker and
we've just brought this story to life in
a 360 degree three-dimensional
experience for everyone to enjoy it is
so cool in here look at you just feel
like you're in the home that you're
seeing right now can you tell me just
how these this video was made for this
experience how are we watching this
um it's a beautiful room of 64
projectors running simultaneously we
have an incredible team that takes this
uh video and Maps it beautifully it's
it's technology that's beyond me but
they're masterful in making this happen
for everyone how long will it be here
we're going to be running the Nutcracker
through January 3rd if you've never been
to the Vincent van Gogh exhibit here you
can still catch it at night but this is
during the day uh yes Nutcracker runs
during the day and we still have Van
Gogh during the evening Guys these
immersive experiences there's so many in
town but how does this one you know
separate itself from the rest
uh well again 360 Degrees three
three-dimensional experience you can see
the kids getting and completely
encompassed in what's going on around
them
um so it's just something for the whole
family to enjoy I I think if you've
never seen The Nutcracker this is how
you see it we're all kids at heart right
I mean it's incredible it's beautiful so
how can you get tickets and come down
and experience you can go to immersive
Dash nutcracker.com tickets start at
29.99 we have family packages premium
tickets come with a gift
um it's something for everyone what kind
of gives they can vary from an ornament
to a mug just something for everybody
great way to kick out the holidays we
have holiday merchandise in our gift
shop as well so please come down okay
well this is the gifts that keeps giving
this immersive experience here the shops
at Crystals you guys bring your family
you can take holiday photos here too
what's up holiday photo absolutely we
have some great photo opportunities yes
everyone should come down it's a great
way to kick off your holiday cards take
a photo well I will send it back to you
I'm gonna go frolic